to achieve your highest goals you have
to be willing to abandon them today
we're publishing the first in a small
series of conversations
with professor ken stanley
reading ken's book why greatness cannot
be planned was one of the most
intellectually awakening moments of the
latter part of my life
it really turned my thinking upside down
making me question
many deeply held beliefs which i had
previously
the episode that we did with him was
many months in the making and perhaps
the greatest ever episode of mlst
ken argued in his book that our world
has become saturated with objectives
the process of setting an objective
attempting to achieve it and measuring
progress along the way has become the
primary route to achievement in our
culture
it's not like he's saying that
objectives are bad per se especially if
they're modest but what he thinks are
that when goals are ambitious which is
to say they are unknowable
complex or abstract
or put more simply that they entail
discovery creativity invention
innovation or happiness
then the search space becomes deceptive
which is to say the measure itself
becomes a false compass which blinds us
to the stepping stones which we should
actually take i mean
is the key to artificial intelligence
really related to intelligence
does taking a job with a higher salary
really bring you closer to being a
millionaire
the problem is that the stepping stones
which lead to ambitious objectives tend
to be pretty strange
they don't resemble the final end state
vacuum tubes led to computers for
example
and youtube started as a video dating
website
in a sense
creativity itself is actually a search
problem
is it possible to explore a search space
intelligently without using an objective
to align towards discovery and away from
the trap of preconceived results
greatness is possible if you're willing
to stop demanding what greatness should
be
the greatest moments and epiphanies in
our life are so often unexpected and
unplanned
serendipity can play an outsized role in
our lives
at the end of joel lemon and ken
stanley's 2011 paper abandoning
objectives they concluded that it was
almost like a riddle
novelty search suggests a surprising new
perspective on achievement which is to
say
to achieve your highest goals
you must be willing to abandon them
i always get engineers on my team to
read this paper and it's illuminating in
so many ways
i love using the visual analogy of a
maze to represent the search problem of
life and stepping stones in that maze as
being either potential objectives
or end states
of course we don't know about the
existence of most of the objectives and
the fog of war blinds us from seeing far
ahead into the maze
the fundamental problem
is the missing information problem but
as we'll soon find out not just the
information itself but how we represent
it
understand it
experience it
and even know it
the fascinating thing is that if we were
an oracle and we knew exactly which
steps to take in life
we could become billionaires within
months or we could achieve anything we
wanted to
the only inconvenient thing stopping us
from realizing our dreams
is that the space of possibilities is
exponentially large
it's very expensive to sample many
trajectories in that space
so we tend to get stuck in certain
sections of the maze for long stretches
of time
ken thinks that the most valuable
commodity in search is information
we must accumulate as much of it as
possible
there's an arrow of informational
complexity and natural evolution
and ken was the first machine learning
researcher to take seriously the growing
yet controversial view in biology that
adaptive selection does not explain the
arrow of complexity in nature
we're standing in a maze right now
there are many doors within walking
distance which lead to unthinkable
greatness
we simply haven't walked over and opened
them
we are existence proofs of general
intelligence every single one of us has
a brain but just like the infinite
number of doors we could open in the
maze of life it took evolution billions
of years and gazillions of individual
life forms to create our brains
now ken is known for his pioneering
research in the open-endedness space you
might recall the poet paper the pairwise
open-ended trailblazer uh it was the
first ever episode of mlst that we spoke
about that but that's an example of this
line of research
open-endedness might seem like a
nebulous term
but you can think of it as being an ai
system which doesn't have a boundary in
its state space and doesn't ever finish
accumulating information
sir arthur stanley eddington
the notorious astronomer and physicist
born in the late 19th century spoke
about the subjectivity in science
his point is that science only tells us
a sliver
of what's really happening in the world
around us
and we should be a lot less arrogant in
our claims to understand it
and our attempts to formalize it
physics he argued can never reveal the
true nature of things
rather it deals with relations between
observables which are subjectively
selected by the human mind
he says that he was inclined to
attribute the whole responsibility for
the laws of mechanics and gravitation to
the mind
and deny the external world any share in
them
he went on to say the laws which we have
hitherto been unable to fit into a
rational scheme
are the true natural laws inherent in
the external world and mind has no
chance of moulding them in accordance
with its own outlook
subjectivity is everywhere and yet in so
many ways we delude ourselves that we
are transforming subjectivity
into objectivity imagine a fisherman
catching fish in a small ocean
depending on the size of his net he
might reason that there's nothing very
small in the ocean because those objects
are slipping through his net
what we can agree on is that our
understanding of physics breaks if we
zoom in too much or zoom out too much
so at best we have a frame of reference
which eddington would argue is observer
relative
surprisingly little in our world can
actually be objectified without using
abstract motifs
have you ever asked a philosopher to
define what it means to be real
or what it means to exist
i can guarantee you that they'll be
reaching
they'll say things like
something exists if it has a causal
effect on the world or if it can be
measured
or if it's not illusory which is to say
uh it is as it appears or you know
perhaps that it's genuine in big air
quotes
what does it mean to be intelligent
what is life
describe an ecosystem
what is british culture
describe your mind
describe your conscious experience
have you heard of the parable of the
blind men and the elephant
any attempt to formalize a complex
phenomena lead to excluding large parts
of the truth what fascinated me about
this conversation with ken this evening
is i got a much deeper understanding of
his philosophy
he led by saying that he thought it's
worth questioning whether artificial
intelligence is even a science or not
just let that sink in for a moment
i'd been too focused on my mental
framework of objectives behavior and
actions the broader story is that ken
thinks society and institutions are
scared of any subjectivity
subjectivity in general
he thinks that attempts to formalize
complex emergent and integrative
phenomena like intelligence
consciousness life society the mind or
anything else for that matter only
deludes us and blocks us from
potentially discovering a deeper reality
later
it's a very human trait to seek to
understand the world around us to
varying degrees of self-delusion before
we understand a particular phenomena
it's almost impossible to come up with a
good scientific and formal definition
how could we possibly define something
which we don't understand well this is
the paradox in computer science and
philosophy the more we seek something
the more it eludes us
it sounds almost anti-intellectual
doesn't it this idea that we should
reject
formalization but ken thinks that many
phenomena will only be trivialized by
vacant attempts to formalize them
through
oversimplification because inevitably
we'll chop off many aspects which might
not be captured by the formalization i
had always associated ken's philosophy
with the missing information problem
rather than the representation problem
the missing information problem is that
we don't know something or we only know
part of the truth
the representation problem is that we
simply don't understand or at least we
can't verbalize what we're experiencing
ken says that the corporate world is
dominated by the attempted veneer of
objectivity
if you're trying to land an engineering
role in fang
your tolerance for ambiguity and
subjectivity
is the single most selective feature of
the level which you get hired at
if you can solve clearly defined
problems you're a level four
if you can find the problems you're a
level six
if you can find the areas
you're a level seven
and if you can find people who can find
the areas you're a level eight or a
level nine
i give loads of open-ended tasks to my
team
discover people in the organization who
are subject matter experts in domain x
build an operating model for knowledge
sharing and standardization
what does good look like
it's possible we don't know it yet which
is the missing information problem but
it's also possible that we know it but
we're not able to verbalize it which is
the representation problem inherence
with all complex phenomena
it's quite interesting actually i'm
building a code review platform called
merge and it's easy to objectify all of
the low-level metrics such as how many
customer engineers we support
or how efficiently we're sharing
knowledge
all of the higher level outcomes like a
better engineering culture
their emergent properties right it's a
bit like pornography you know it when
you see it
so now
i give you
professor ken stanley we have a nose for
the interesting that's how we got this
far that's how civilization came out
that's why the history of innovation is
so amazing
everything washes out when we start
ruling by committee like we have to
allow people to follow their passions to
their extremes and yet we run society as
if this actually makes any sense at all
i think the gradient of interestingness
is probably the best expression of like
the ideal divergent search you get to
this problem that like i don't know how
to formalize interestingness what you
get to then are proxies for
interestingness that not everything
that's novel is interesting but just
about everything that's interesting is
novel it is in my personality in nature
to want to overthrow this i guess we
could say tyranny of objectives
so today
we have an incredibly special guest
indeed my hero and ai professor kenneth
stanley now the kenneth stanley show
that we filmed which is to say episode
38 was my favorite episode that we've
ever done reading ken this book why
greatness cannot be planned and
preparing for that show triggered an
incredible amount of intellectual growth
for me and a hallmark of that you know
when you learn something profound
is that you start recognizing it in many
other domains of your life i mean you
remember when you learned probability
theory for the first time and you
started seeing exponential distributions
absolutely everywhere um so i was just
saying to kenneth that when we listened
back to the show last night um it was
probably the best example ever of a show
we over prepared for which to say that
during the interview we were just
bamboozling kenneth we were so excited
we almost couldn't control ourselves and
um i think in particular keith and
kenneth reach common ground actually in
the sense that divergence and
convergence don't have to be hyperbolic
or entirely mutually exclusive now
kenneth thinks that we have a nose for
the interesting that's how we got this
far it's the basis of all innovation and
the secret of our society kenneth
believes that the concept of deception
in search which is to say getting stuck
in local optimums and indeed deluding
ourselves that we even know what good
looks like in the first place is what
regularly sends us into brick walls
kenneth thinks that institutions are
full of gatekeepers and the gatekeepers
only want to see your objectives and
metrics any expert on search would know
that it's completely naive and yet we
still use this approach for the most
complex problems in our society
committees wash out everything we need
to let people follow their interests to
the extremes and risk has to be
tolerated in order to make the greatest
discoveries anyway professor keller
stanley it's an absolute honor to have
you back on the show
thank you for having me here
so it's been great i really enjoyed
being on it and i'm glad to be back here
i mean even the thing you made in front
of that that show was awesome like that
was
i showed that to my son and he was like
what the heck is that he's like that's
not my dad and i was like that is he's
like you've never seen me in that kind
of that's funny environment but it was
pretty cool
oh yeah so we we painted a cafe in
behind you but we we did that first
thing in blender but i had to learn
blender just for that it was the first
thing i ever did and what i started
doing afterwards i i wish that we did
your show a tiny bit later i started
using my virtual reality headset so i've
got an oculus quest and then you i use
google tilt brush
and then i can kind of create a
beautiful 3d environment i can put
slides and videos and all kinds of stuff
up there and that would have been
perfect for that because i wanted to
show all of the stepping stones in the
divergent uh search in a in a 3d
environment but that's a cool thing
we're getting more sophisticated and
we're starting to use you know manum to
do animations because we want to be able
to really kind of at least for some of
the episodes tell the story in a very
visual and and educational way so we're
kind of going back now revisiting some
of our favorite
you know favorite episodes and can we
tell parts of it again with this this
new
technology if you will or new techniques
that we have skills that's cool yeah
i gotta tell you on just um on a
personal note because you mentioned you
know your son saying that's not my dad
part of my motivation for for doing
these these youtube you know shows is
that i want there to be something where
my kids can go maybe when i'm gone or
whatever and look back and say oh yeah
that was my dad that's what he sounded
like that's what he looked like you know
that's how he thought
it's a really nice thing yeah
yeah yeah the problem is no one
understands what we're talking about
well maybe they were my friends and
family they say oh i tried to watch it
but i just couldn't understand what you
were talking about
it's so funny because from my
perspective we're really um making
things accessible and dummy things down
as much as possible and yeah and i still
think of myself as completely clueless
but it's quite deceptive isn't it that
you you don't realize you're talking
another language yeah it's funny i mean
my mom i you know i said here's this
video and she actually has no idea what
i mean this isn't but she showed her
sister who's like 80 years old and
didn't know anything
and her sister was just like you know
you
it seemed like you're really winning in
that discussion you have no idea what
you're talking about that's cool well
that's good i mean at least the tone
sounded like i'm winning
and well yeah i mean it's kind of funny
well speaking speaking of winning and
that's kind of the question i wanted to
ask you is that
you know it's one of those ideas tim
mentioned these kind of ideas that the
first time you hear them and after you
kind of digest them a bit then you start
seeing them everywhere and you start
seeing you know connections
connections to it everywhere and i think
i think your ideas are like that at
least they were they were for me and
i've i started to come to um
this line of thinking that i just wanted
to ask you about just to see if it's
completely off base or if there's any
maybe any kind of truth to it which is
um and i know i keep repeating this to
him and i apologize but one of the most
beautiful quotes i ever heard was from
from claude shannon
many decades ago i heard this and he
said
uh
you know we have knowledge of the past
but we cannot change it
we have no knowledge of the future
but we control it
and i realized back then that there's
this this duality and it's it's
reflected there in that asymmetry of
time but also in the way i think about
science and engineering so there are the
two sides of a coin where
scientists use engineering to control
in order to gain new knowledge
whereas engineers take the knowledge
that we have and they use it to gain
control you know by building a better
building crossing a water stream or
whatever and it's also similar to the
exploration versus exploitation
you know trade-off and i'm coming around
to this way of thinking that
yeah you know uh objectives
can be quite harmful when you're in that
exploration
you know phase trying to learn new
knowledge because just as you point out
who knows what the stepping stones are
going to be like and all the kind of
let's say quote unquote counter examples
that i was thinking of before it's
because they fall more in the
engineering side of things which is okay
look we have some knowledge and we do
have a very specific goal we're trying
to do
with that knowledge you know build a
faster rocket or whatever and so yeah we
just go down this kind of very
refinement objective based kind of goal
but it's really not going to lead us
necessarily to new new knowledge or new
insight is this kind of a fair
dichotomy or not
yeah i mean um you know nice cute to
hear you're coming coming around to that
way of thinking somewhat um
um
it's um
yeah it's it's interesting to uh connect
this to shannon that that i appreciate
and there's an interesting connection
and
um i think the dichotomy is is pretty
fair um that
um
like in search of discovery
yeah a lot of engineering principles are
not really the best tools um for for
innovation necessarily especially basic
like basic exploration
um
and um it's true also that it seems like
engineering
culturally kind of pervades
scientific education at least in some
sciences i don't know like i only know
about my own experience in computer
science but
like i was in computer science
engineering major at upenn that was like
computer science engineering is like one
thing
um and so yeah like a lot of engineering
philosophy is like stuck in with the
science
um and maybe maybe maybe there is um
like some
uh conflation there um but i also think
like another thing to consider which
might be a little bit more out there and
um
controversial is that um
i think it's worth questioning whether
compu artificial intelligence really is
only science
um is that is that actually what we're
doing um like a lot of the discussion
about
ai
um we'll come back to um
you know that's not scientific or
there's a kind of attack or a way of
looking at like
an idea where like we can sort of invoke
science snobbery um to put something
down
um and you know one interpretation is
just that um
you know maybe there it was a good
scientific insight but but somebody just
missed it or something they're not
seeing the big picture another
interpretation is that actually this is
not science
and it shouldn't be it shouldn't be um
caged inside of that only that way of
thinking
um
and i've actually
i've written about this was much less
received much less attention when i
wrote about it but i thought a lot about
it like that in some ways i think ai is
is has a lot of connection to art
um and i don't mean just in the sense
that like you can use ai to generate art
i mean you can do that obviously but i
mean in the sense that like art is about
um the reproduction
often not always but often it's about
the reproduction of natural artifacts in
an artificial way like i mean when you
when you paint a picture of like an
apple or something like a still life
and nobody's expecting it to be a real
apple like that's not the question um
and nobody even expects there's
necessarily a faithful reproduction of
an apple or let's say like you know van
gogh's starry night it doesn't look
anything like a real story and i did i
bet anybody on earth has ever seen even
if they're on drugs
and yet
what does it do what what is the value
of starry night then since it's not it's
not accurate scientifically it's not a
very good job
um well it actually gives you new
insight
into something about starry nights that
you hadn't really thought about
um and that's what's thrilling about it
is that like it gives you a new
perspective on something that you're
familiar with
ai is also concerned with the
reproduction of natural phenomena in
artifice um it's the same thing
and uh in a similar way like an
algorithm is i i think it's just another
way it's kind of like another painting
um it's just a painting that's expressed
rather than through brush strokes it's
expressed through code um but if you
look at it that way you can understand
that like it can be an interpretation of
nature without being accurate
and that can still be valuable just as
starry night is valuable
and the reason it can be valuable back
to science is because some of the
thoughts it gives you will be stepping
stones that then lead back to scientific
insights so we're straddling between
science and art here but the thing is
it's not necessarily a harmful thing to
do
um and so we we should actually consider
whether like to the extent that an
algorithm actually is an artistic
inspiration which i think a lot of what
i was doing was like when i was building
things like neat i was inspired by like
the increases in complexity in nature i
was never under the delusion that need
is an accurate depiction of how
evolution works in nature but it's kind
of an ode to nature in a way like the
way a painting might be um was never
discussed in that light
you said in in your presentation last
time that um you was becoming a little
bit more radicalized because you were
doing it to not computer scientist
artists and all of a sudden they were
saying to you oh my god kenneth like
finally my parents keep saying to me why
are you doing art why are you wasting
your time and now i understand now i
actually have a sense of purpose it
means something and i think what you
were saying a second ago because it's
quite interesting you said or a starry
night and you could say that's a kind of
model or a kind of representation but is
it fair to say that you're actually more
interested in analogizing the process
itself
like analogizing the process of
discovery in ai with our is it that's
what you mean yeah i i think there's an
analogy between art and ai it's more
than just process it's like it is a
branch of art like it's literally about
like reproduction reproducing natural
phenomena in artifice which is what
artists do um
the difference is that the um
the
i mean art is
you know you might say it's like there's
more of an aesthetic emphasis or
something in art but but i mean it's
just a choice
um i mean that's what we're doing in ai
um we're interested in so one one
exception i should say for the artists
who are listening which are probably few
uh but but i want to acknowledge that
that's not the only thing art is
concerned with when i wrote about this i
actually i wrote a paper on this it was
um one of the weirdest things i did
because i actually went to like a real
library and was researching art history
and things like that i felt like a real
like scholar or something in the library
but um i so i got a lot of i got some
criticism from artists and like one of
the things they were pointing out was
that it's not always about the
reproduction of nature like at least
there's some modern art that has nothing
to do with reproducing anything it's
just about like the pure aesthetics so
let's just acknowledge that that's not
all art is about but much of our
throughout art history has been about
that it's certainly a part of art is to
do is to reproduce natural phenomena in
artifice and that's what our ai is
so it's not just a connection i think it
is art um it's just that we're not
willing to discuss that side of it
because we're very we're very proud of
ourselves for being scientists it makes
us feel good about ourselves but the
reason i started thinking about this is
because i started i was getting in some
arguments with people where the kind of
um the crux the breaking point where
they tried to basically stop it and say
this is the end of the argument was
basically to say that what i was saying
was not scientific
um or like this is not a scientific
question it can't be objectively
analyzed um you can't get an objective
you can't get falsification on this
question so it's basically not subject
to debate like let's not talk about it
because it's pointless and i felt like
that is just pure cowardice like we are
you are just saying you are afraid to
inquire in directions where you don't
know how to falsify
to me that's just cowardice and i do not
like associating science with cowardice
um and i started thinking about you know
am i really doing science
like maybe there's another view here
like i don't know that i was like fully
just trying to to generate hypotheses
and validate or falsify them um there's
an artistic side to i think creating
these algorithms um and i think it might
be healthy to acknowledge that it's
interesting to think about
i i think your frame of reference
doesn't seem to fit into the paradigm of
science in so many ways and i remember
you said on the show last time that you
were exasperated that um pick breeder
was not recognized as being
scientifically useful and there was
another convergent um committee version
of pick breeder and then the images just
looked like um wallpaper backgrounds but
um to your point before i i kind of
agree of you that when you look at what
happens in in the process of art
it seems very intelligent but i'm trying
to understand where the intelligence
lies because i'm interested in in the
idea of of it being embodied for example
and an emergent phenomenon and so
clearly when human beings
collaborate together in this divergent
way that's that's something very
interesting but um what would happen if
the agents producing the art were much
less intelligent than humans
do you think that could still lead to
a kind of intelligence um at a larger
scale mm-hmm
yeah and and
i just want to also like preface by just
saying that i'm not against science i
don't i do i do like being associated
with science i don't i don't want to be
now categorized as an artist only
um i just think that we're straddling
both here um and and the mechanisms of
science clearly have served us well in
many cases so i just i don't want to be
associated with kooky views that like we
should get rid of science or something
like that i just think it's expands our
horizons to understand what we're doing
and how it relates to art
um and i also just before to answer the
question i think it's also important to
note that i'm not just making the
generic point that like there's an
aesthetic aspect to science like which
people have written entire books about
like people have pointed out before not
not me but like there's famous books um
that have been written about how
uh you know science has an artistic side
like an artistic inclination can help
you as a scientist like i mean this is
not new to to point these things out um
but i'm trying to make a much more
literal point that ai itself
specifically ai with the word artificial
in front of it is really about art in a
strong way um and this is what has not
been acknowledged this point has also
come up in in mathematics and for the
life of me i can't think of you know
whether it was penrose or maybe even
gauss or somebody but a legendary
mathematician made this point they were
they were bemoaning the fact that there
wasn't more creativity
in mathematics because if you look at
some of the greatest achievements
of mathematics they were these things
that were created that were entirely new
uh you know like like um uh
calculus you know from leidness or
newton right i mean just these
new creations new ways of thinking about
things um that were really inspired from
a more artistic sense
and and he was he was making the same
point that like that's mathematics and
to kind of say like well no if it
doesn't have a certain level of rigor
you know doesn't approach mathematics
well in order to get to those those
forms of rigor you first have to have
that stepping stone that inspiration you
know that generates you know something
brand new and i i gotta fight figure
this out but i forget who it was um and
they made this point so if it applies
even a mathematics you know it has to
apply also to things that are more
grounded in reality so i think your
point completely stands and um
you know it is it is sad that it tried
that people try to dismiss it as well
that's not science or that's not
mathematics
it's an interesting response there's
like good it's not science like i wonder
where that leads exactly it's like i'm
not pretending to be talking about
science like it's still something we
should discuss good it's not already
known it's i'm doing something new
yeah
so where where does the intelligence lie
i think was where i was getting out
i'm really fascinated by this idea that
it's not in the brain that it's in the
process and i i think your ideas are
going in that direction yeah i remember
your question yeah yeah so like would
you like if a less intelligent if there
was a less intelligent
kind of move towards art or less
intelligent um type of agent that was um
involved in an artistic evolution like
what what would be the quality of that
um
yeah i think um i do think it's possible
for there to be
artistic it's
it's complicated because like
art is subjective i mean we're making it
for ourselves
so like
like if there were things that aren't us
that are doing something artistic like
presumably they're making it for
themselves so it might not be
interesting to us i'm not sure it might
be interesting to us um but it would it
would be a process worth paying
attention to in some way um i do believe
that um because it would it would have
these um these properties of
you know trends and stepping stones and
um like an evolutionary process like a
phylogeny would result from that
um whether it's of interest to us is i
mean just the the artifacts themselves
i'm not i'm not totally sure that they
would be um because because a lot of i
mean art does often reference things
like i said in nature because that's
what our experience is i mean if you
have no experience of nature
uh
or it can't be about that then um so
what is it about it just it could be
about other things just mathematical
relationships some some small subset of
art is like i said like i mean some
modern art has nothing to do with
referencing anything in the world
um but um but
so maybe some people would appreciate
that um but even those things seem to
relate to some emotional resonance or
something like that like these these
beings may have no emotion
um so i don't know we would enjoy this
but um but from a kind of like just like
analyzing the process point of view i
think it might be interesting because
there would be such a process
it's it's so interesting because the
rubber meets the road
we're talking about this um all of these
brains operating together in this
divergent process and you were just
saying that an artist possibly has some
kind of phenomenological resonance with
a situation and um i'm interested in in
the kind of continuum between brains and
the kind of algorithms we produce in
computer science because i think we
could all agree that neural networks and
optimization algorithms they don't seem
very human-like and they certainly don't
don't think the way humans do even if
they can produce intelligent seeming
behavior so you really lean into this
idea of trusting our instincts and
subjectivity and a cynical reading is
that our subjectivity is essentially
random and a random search would be the
most divergent search but that would
clearly be rubbish right so there must
be some kind of continuum between a
totally random search and a principled
divergent research so how would you kind
of articulate and reason about that
yeah um it's true that um that any kind
of divergence that
pushes too far towards randomness i
don't think would be interesting
and i don't think that's what artists i
don't think that's what human artists
are doing because i don't think it would
be interesting
it's just that
art is
they are they are really concerned with
what's interesting i think um but
without the constraints of science so
it's not supposed to prove something
that you you're trying to figure out
whether it's true or not um it's just
supposed to lead to some kind of insight
or feeling or something it depends on
the artist and of course that then
points back to things we care about like
because we're humans and we care about
having insights and of course the things
we want to have insights about vary but
like generally art that we appreciate
like leads you to having some
realization that is generally commonly
held like that people would agree is
interesting
um and so um
the artists are exploring that um and
that's leads to other ideas um that
might not be art um you know i think
yeah like a scientist can be inspired
inspired by art
to think about a phenomenon or or
somebody else can be inspired architect
obviously many times inspired by arts
there's lots of inspiration that comes
out of our philosophical as well like
about like how the world works and what
matters um there's plenty of topics to
talk about that aren't that aren't
falsifiable in a scientific sense
um and you know with with ai algorithms
they
i think secretly a lot of the
explanation for what has risen and
fallen within that within ai
is that not not the actual scientific
results
is that people have resonated i like
that word because that's really about
art it's not it's not about correctness
or accuracy it's about resonance and
people have resonated with certain
algorithms it's like they just felt it
it got to a point was this like an
artistic realization not a scientific
realization like where it resonated with
some sense of what intelligence is for
you
um and it's not like the whole thing
nobody get the whole deal of
intelligence obviously but some part of
it like resonates
and um that can be extremely inspiring
and i think explains certain like
inflection points in the history of
machine learning
where i think it was resonance really
that explains it yeah and i think so
it's really interesting what you're
saying and and i think there's a
tendency of um of some
uh to again dismiss this type of thing
as
not science woo
you know whatever but i think that stems
from a
a uh being insufficiently darwinian in
the sense that look
whatever's up in our brain okay it's the
beneficiary of a billion years
of of evolution okay and these these
insights and intuitions that we have
even if we're not conscious of them
maybe they're not happening at a level
that we can
analytically break down you know
consciously and think about
could still be extremely useful and
extremely valuable and so i have no
doubt believing that when a human mind
sees an algorithm even
it can perceive you know some
connections to some abstract concepts
that have been proven out through
evolution as being highly highly useful
and so you may be seeing those
connections is that
i mean does that capture potentially a
fair and scientific justification of why
we should pay attention to
intuition and artistic intuition
yeah i think it's fair i i think
i think though i wouldn't only um couch
it in terms of evolution i think it's
broader than just from evolution like
it's from our experience also like
experienced since you were born
um and that's that's your memories and
and the feelings that you've had over
the course of your life that i think
enter into uh
of course just some evolution
explanation for for how you process
those experiences but but the
experiences are also part of the
background for what you appreciate and
find interesting in your life
and um and i yeah i think that that
is um as you say um a um an important
part of
the the history of ideas even in science
and what i guess what is it actu what's
actionable about that though is that
it's interesting to think about the
extent to which
we should we should actually um allow or
facilitate discussion on this level not
at this meta level like we're talking
about just should we do this but at the
level of
here is what resonates to me like about
this specific thing this is why it's
like as a reviewer
like i don't i don't care if it gets
like five percent less accuracy on this
set it's super interesting because xyz
um it reminds me of something powerfully
reminds me like can we have discussions
like this um we can't right now um and
so it's interesting just to think about
that like would it would it help to
facilitate progress
with its timing progress because i think
most people their first gut instinct is
it's bad for progress because it opens
the floodgates of sort of like
unregulated like unempirical type of
speculation and we're all afraid of that
but i am i think we should we should be
cautious but i think we're too afraid of
it um and that like we can handle this
because like we we actually know about
what we're talking about like that's the
thing that makes this valid like it's
again like if it's just some random
person on the street i wouldn't want to
have an aesthetic discussion of
algorithms um but if it's experts i
don't understand why we're not allowed
to have aesthetic feelings and relating
things in in like analogizing things
like that seem perfectly fine we should
be able to do i'd say even if you can't
do that there's a problem
like what why are you an expert like if
you can't make analogies and actually
talk about what's interesting or
inspiring about the work
okay one thing that i'm wrestling with a
little bit here is i mean douglas
hoffstatter the famous douglas
hofstadter he once said that he was
terrified that ai might be
disappointingly simple to mechanize and
i think a lot of the stuff that we're
talking about here is i mean we're
talking about subjectivity but also
we're talking about the externalization
of of intelligence so rather than it
being
encapsulated in an individual brain and
a lot of it is is emergent and and can
be thought of as as
something completely different i i um
i'm concerned about the lack of the lack
of free will for want of a better um
so we've been dealt that the the
experiences and the environment that we
have in life and to a certain extent is
it still intelligent if
our cards are marked
if if everything has been mapped out in
my life as a function of the environment
that that i'm in and my life experiences
i i guess i have this just as as douglas
hofstadter did i have this very fanciful
um idea in my mind of what intelligence
is that it's infinitely nuanced and we
have this phenomenological experience
and and uh you know for example um
hofstadter spoke about chopin
this this beautiful piece of music and
what the infinite nuance and subtlety
that must have gone through his mind
when he created it and wouldn't it be
horrible if if that was just the result
of quite a simple
um process that you could define using
code
but this is an interesting question um
i think um
yeah it's clear that there's a movement
in machine learning towards that kind of
perspective of basically simplicity and
it goes back before deep learning i mean
if people were observing that they say
well like you know cortical circuits
like in the brain all share like a huge
amount of similarity it's like it is
possible it's all the same algorithm all
throughout and there's just some simple
explanation
and then like when we see like things
like really large large language models
that are basically like uniform
architectural structures um that just
get bigger
um it seems to it seems to point in that
direction that like it's not like a
bunch of really complex rich subtlety
like going on through the system
um
we don't know though yet we don't know i
mean
the jury's still out we haven't actually
gotten to human level
and um
i think that
yeah and i mean you can also you can
also point to evolutionary processes too
and say they're all so simple like
there's a simple thing and it's this is
explains everything like it's not really
that interesting of a thing in and of
itself
i don't i guess to me it's just we would
like to know the answer to this like can
you actually get these things to work
through very simple processes that's
probably really important um to know
like just in terms of being able to do
machine learning
um but i don't think for me it would be
um
that disappointing one way or another i
think i because i think the subtlety is
still in there
um it just came in through a different
channel like okay maybe the subtlety is
not in the architecture i i personally
think there is subtlety in the
architecture that's my guess like it's
not going to be super simple
um but but let's say it doesn't have to
be it could be all like uniform
um but then like what you what you do
and what you care about can still
be like the constellation of stuff that
you learned which you learned over your
lifetime like what that amount to
in aggregate can still be i think
highly rich and and subtle in its
connectivity
it's just a structure that emerged from
a simple process which allowed it to
emerge but then the structure itself is
complex um so i don't think it would
diminish sort of like the the the
grandiosity of like what we are
to me i could see other people might
think otherwise but it's it's okay um i
don't know what the actual truth is but
that wouldn't necessarily bother me yeah
i agree with you it doesn't it doesn't
decrease the grandiosity of what we are
consciousness you're talking about i was
surprised that they got in so much um
conversation it's um
i didn't realize it struck a chord i
find that i think we don't know what the
motivation is behind that tweet um it's
um
uh
i'm assuming it was meant to provoke
conversation there's no depth in that
tweet at all but it's not because it's
dumb it's because like it's a tweet and
there's no room to actually talk about
all the complexity of the issue and so
i'm assuming that he's not actually
making an argument that he even thinks
is like persuasive one way or another
he's just provoking discussion
and as such i think it's effective it
provoked discussion certainly we've got
a lot of discussion going and allowed
people to show their cards on this and
i'm actually curious about what people's
cards are on this like people don't talk
about this that much i think it's not
it's not immediately germaned making
progress in machine learning so it's in
some ways you might think it was a waste
of time because we can't really use this
discussion to get anywhere and people
are busy trying to publish papers and
stuff but i'm just just personally
curious like about what people think in
this field because it's obviously
relevant like to what we're trying to do
i mean maybe we're connected into quite
a lot of the symbolic community and on
linkedin everyone was just posting
saying oh my god that you know this hype
is getting out of control the runaway
train of deep learning now it's like oh
you're basically just like feeding into
the hype but i could interpret that too
is completely independent from deep
learning height
wow just basically saying like is there
a threshold that's crossed
um where there actually is like
conscious phenomena happening
um
and it doesn't mean that what we're
doing is right at all right now it's
still an interesting i love i love it
because it's it is provoking this this
conversation that uh you know we need to
be a bit more
um defined and what we mean by
consciousness or at least to think about
it so i thought i thought it was for the
purpose that ken thinks which is to
provoke conversation
and i will admit it provoked me to tweet
something i i actually don't tweet
but actually tweeted something last
night because i just couldn't resist it
uh
unconsciousness what did you tweet um i
don't know if it'll upset you maybe i
don't know yeah tell us what did you do
what's up
would i tweet i'd have to look at my
phone to remember what i said exactly
trigger warning
be careful
yeah so this is actually connected to
our discussion in some subtle way here
that we've been having because like
using my tweet unconsciousness i was
pointing out that
um i've noticed like since the original
consciousness tweet like a lot of people
making off-handed comments basically
dismissing consciousness is not a good
topic
because it lacks an objective measure
this is this is an easy way to get out
of this
um and the thing that's being missed
here is that is precisely why it's
fascinating like it is the phenomenon of
subjectivity it cannot have an objective
measure unless we're talking about a
superficial aspect of it but the
interesting aspect of it is the part
that's hard to talk about
and so it's literally what it's like
from the inside and so the idea that we
cannot discuss that it's an interesting
idea is exactly the kind of cowardice
that i'm talking about we're using
science to block us from exploring
something that's uncomfortable um and if
science lacks the tools like if that's
what we're saying it lacks the tools um
to address consciousness because it is
subjective that's not an indictment of
consciousness as a concept it's an
indictment of science that's what got me
there i must admit that's that's a very
clever response
yeah i don't know how to respond to that
but i mean i personally like to think of
consciousness as being the you know like
qualia and the the subjective
phenomenological experience and and i
thought it was a stretch to say that
something like gpt-3 could possibly have
any kind of subjective experience i i
find it a stretch that did you have
subjective experience i mean or did i do
i mean why why a bag of atoms as a
subjective experience like qualia no
idea why that would be this this is the
problem right so we know
quite a few people and they are so
cynical and they argue that um
intelligence is just a pilot trick that
gpg3 is is intelligent and we're not
really intelligent and when when when
we're doing you know when we think we're
thinking we're just doing some hash
table look up and it's all a trick
yeah
oh wait i mean yeah i mean and there are
people that have argued that
consciousness is just like a trick it's
a you're you're and we're just confused
when we think we're conscious it's
really nothing special going on yeah i
mean if you take that view then none of
this is very interesting i don't take
that view because i believe that there
are qualia but that's just a belief i
can't prove anything um but then again
how could i it's a subjective discussion
um and so like the real you know the
real issue at hand here is like whether
we think that subjective phenomena are
real like do they actually exist
um and um it's to me it's worth
discussing um even though it's actually
outside of the bounds of current science
i don't know any way that we can look at
this empirically um but i i don't find
that ambiguity uncomfortable i think
it's interesting i like things that are
good use that's where we start learning
things i have to hand it to you you've
really got me
there well um that's good yeah
yeah i mean part of this um and some of
those points are somewhat
old like the point has been made i think
many times that science's lack of
ability to describe consciousness
is not an indictment of of consciousness
it's an indictment of science i mean
there's there's things missing from it
we need to expand it a bit that you're
quoting a tweet there but someone
probably i'm just saying it's yeah it's
it's kind of an old indictment of it but
i think what i often see is that um
you know people often cling to kind of
extreme definitions of things because if
they're confronted with a middle ground
that's completely reasonable it's just
boring like they almost just can't
accept that that's the answer you know
for example for me you know
consciousness
from my perspective uh it's definitely a
pattern of neural activity
in the brain and it's probably one
that's doing something like analyzing
the neural activity of other parts of
the brain and or itself
and that's it like it's you know what's
what's the big mystery here but
but that that definition is almost like
too easy and too reasonable and then we
have to start talking about yeah but
what does it feel like to be that
you know that that pattern of neurons
and i saw this happen like in a debate
between uh daniel bennett and sam harris
about um free will okay where daniel
dennett is saying look
to me free will
is the fact that you can evaluate
options and shoot you know you evaluate
those options and one path is taken
based on that evaluation so for example
a chess program if it's evaluating the
board possibility in doing a monte carlo
tree search and it evaluates one as
being the best option and it takes that
path
that's free will in other words it's
freedom of freedom of parameter space
it's you know freedom freedom of options
and sam harris's only response to that
is like well
okay but that's not what people think
like that's not what somebody on the
street says is free will they they think
it's this magical thing that well who
cares i mean who cares what
what people think is is surprising like
there's people that believe all kinds of
things that that don't
have any type of scientific basis or
mathematical basis we find a very
reasonable definition
of free will that's totally compatible
with the reality and the pragmatic
experience of free will and yet because
it's surprising to some people or
because it's too boring we just refuse
to accept it
yeah well
you noted that like people tend to
gravitate to extreme positions um a lot
it's pretty clear in politics too for a
lot of reasons
um but i also think there's something
about human nature
where people don't like to say i don't
know
um
and that's like um it's really
interesting i think that we don't admit
we don't know people respond with
certitude to things that we have
absolutely no idea about and i feel like
that is much more of the issue with
consciousness
is that we really don't know and i did i
disagree with uh with like sir dennis
position because it's about he's
claiming to know
um and i i i think that it's actually
most courageous just to say i don't
really know what's going on here and i
can the reason i think it's totally
reasonable to say we don't know is
because look it polarizes all of us
like this is one of those issues where
experts can come out of completely
different extremes um and there's no
consensus and like when that's happening
probably nobody knows what's going on um
we have not come to consensus yet and so
i think there is something deeper going
on here um that that needs to be
addressed and it's not simple and
certitude is not the right response um
so to me it's just i i would say i don't
really know but i would like i would i
find interesting to delve into what it
is that i don't know like the details of
what we don't know because that's where
it gets interesting there's lots of
things we do know which is what tends to
get rehashed when we respond with
certitude like i know what i know but i
don't i don't i'm more interested let me
just follow up there so this was a
debate between two extremists one
extremist saying there's no such thing
as free will it's an illusion
and and the other one actually a middle
ground but at least extreme from a
certainty you know perspective which is
saying here's a definition but the
reason why i gravitate towards that
position is because it at least provides
us with an operational paradigm by which
we can do exactly what you're suggesting
which is explore what we don't know so
if we take it as like okay here's a
working definition of free will now
let's find all the areas where it breaks
down explore them scientifically yeah
useful right whereas in extreme
positions saying yeah no nothing is free
will it's an illusion it's not useful i
can't do anything with that
and i think it's it's quite hard to have
a definition i was challenging one of my
friends yesterday kenneth about imagine
you wanted to become a billionaire um
give me an objective to optimize
and
it's really really difficult because you
can start to scratch around and talk
about diversity and information
accumulation all the stuff novelty
interestingness but you're really
scratching around and it's the same
thing here we're talking about um
consciousness and free will
and these are very subjective things and
when keith was talking about the sam
harris debate
um because it's not like free will is
about um
max you know maximizing the expected
reward although perhaps if you created
an agent to do such a thing it would
maybe you could tune it to behave in
such a way as humans behave
but um
from my perspective free will is about
the subjectivity and about the agency
those two things and i can't really
describe those two things in any more
detail than that
yeah
well one one distinction that i think i
want to make is that um
i would separate in my kind of like
questioning and thinking free will from
from consciousness like i i think it's
two different questions for me i could
see why you might want to combine them
but i just think they're different
i've thought much more about
consciousness and free will so i would
and that i think i'm not i haven't
really thought through how to address
free will very well um
um but unconsciousness i think i to me
it's about the issue that's that's
really um problematic is when it comes
to like quality and things like that
like there are other aspects of
consciousness we might talk about that
they think are less problematic but that
is very mysterious and i feel unresolved
in any case we're making a general point
here about these kinds of discussions
and um
yeah i think the the general points that
keith is making are reasonable
um and so yeah we um have david chalmers
coming on the show next month
oh i was gonna say did you read his book
i mean that's that's like now that was a
book i really like that book because it
is about not knowing
the book is basically trying to tell
that's how i interpret i'm no
philosopher so maybe i don't even
understand what i'm reading but my
interpretation was basically a big
argument about what we why we should
admit that we really don't know what's
going on
there's very few books like that i love
a good book about not knowing things i
don't know if you guys know that um like
one of the very first
neuroevolution experiments because i was
in the field of neuroevolution was
chalmers he actually did it
um long before all this stuff is famous
wow
he re-evolved the rules of
backpropagation
amazing
i've saved him many times for that
amazing he comes up absolutely
everywhere he's such an interesting guy
i wanted to talk a little bit about some
of that stuff because um there's not
there's not a lot of new work in your
space at the moment and i suppose like
one way to frame the question is clearly
um poet and enhanced poet are
fascinating and um they are much more
divergent than many other algorithms but
are you aware of anything which has been
artificially created which is extremely
divergent i mean more so than poet even
or is that currently the state of the
art
well
there are still things going on like one
one place to look is under the name
quality diversity
um like you can find a whole a website
it's called i think it's called quality
diversity optimization unfortunately the
word optimization i wouldn't have put in
there but
um that's what they're calling it and
that's basically about you know qd
algorithms are basically about like
novelty like novelty seeking things
combined with a notion of quality
and um so you can see like the latest
there like those are divergent in at
some level like almost every paper
there's like 150 i think the last time i
looked
um but it but it's the thing about it is
it is it is not yet connected to the
mainstream of machine learning which is
why you're not hearing about it or
noticing it as much that's always been a
problem historically going back to
neuroevolution
um it's often evolutionary um but there
are some there is some drift out of that
i think recently like um people have
sent me preprints i think something's
going to come out soon for example
trying to build on like the idea of poet
um and like that are much more kind of
machine learning reinforcement learning
oriented
um and so there will be things there's a
trickle coming out in that direction
and then and now we're seeing like
there's open-ended learning symposium
workshops like popping up at mainstream
conferences i know i'm speaking at um i
guess
is it iclear i think there's going to be
a workshop on open-endedness um
and so so there's definitely some
momentum i think it's still
early and could fizzle out but but
you're seeing stuff um
but in any case
to the question do we actually see
something more open than poet i think
the answer is no currently i'm not aware
of everything going on but that's a
pretty um
like
maybe like there's some things that
improve on it in one way or another but
i wouldn't call it more open-ended no i
think that that's that's a pretty high
bar like um
and it's there is there is red room i
think to be more open-ended than poet
but it's a high bar it's really hard
and um
i think when people
when people see poet they focus from
machine learning perspective they focus
more on the curriculum learning aspect
of it
like like the curriculum learning aspect
is like a certain perspective you could
have and you could think about it as
like you know how do we get
something really intelligent for a
certain kind of problem that has
generality like i think about something
like that and this is like give some
clues in that direction but that's
that's not really going towards with the
part that like inspires me it's the
open-endedness side of it you know which
i what i really want to see is that it
just continues to invent like totally
out of the blue crazy stuff forever
and that like seems to get less mind
share like that kind of question um
maybe because it's not very practical
and nobody's really sure what we're even
talking about like what crazy things you
actually want to see
um but i i would i that's the kind of
thing where i don't think we're seeing a
lot of a lot of push or progress on the
curriculum learning i do think we see
things
um and they are interesting within that
context yeah the curriculum learning
thing fascinates me because i remember
talking um i think icml 2019 and he was
saying look on poet there's an example
of
an agent and we have this curriculum and
sometimes we need to kind of shift
between a very kind of
complex environment and then back to a
simple environment in order to solve
this particular problem but you spoke
about generality
and i would still argue that the the
kind of program learned by poet doesn't
have generality but the um the process
which produced it does so francois chole
has this measure of intelligence
conception and he he he has this idea of
intelligence being a process so there's
like a metal learning process and then
it can produce skill programs which can
then work in any particular situation so
i mean is that similar to your mindset
so i agree that it doesn't have
generality that's totally true it's it's
it's a totally about
hyper-specialization this gets to
actually the art asp the art discussion
we were having before
to me that is that is that is
artistically appealing um because it's
evocative of nature
where like you're not going for a super
generalist in general like like each
niche is basically like a
hyper-specialized niche um which which
interestingly eventually led to extreme
generality like with like us like we
have an extreme level of generality in
certain ways like it's certainly not
photosynthetic so we don't have that
kind of generality but we have
intelligent generality but it went
through hyper specialization
um you know like if you go back to the
ancestry you're looking at hyper
specialists not generalists that are
trying to become more and more
intelligent like you're looking at
things like flatworms again or not
general generalists in any sense like
it's a new reorganization of the body
plan
um and so i find first of all just from
an artistic perspective find
um the
the way the depiction of something that
is about like continually branching and
just interesting aesthetically
and something that we should create like
we should create things that do that um
but what i notice is that always people
point to that as a weakness and say well
there's a caveat here it's very
specialist oriented you know
you know why not go for generality and
actually you could like um this is like
a fairly intuitive notion that like yeah
we can get divergent curricula but try
to to focus it back down to a
centralized point where we're trying to
get generality i mean i'm not going to
give an exact way you can do that but
this is like a intuitive concept i think
to think about doing that right um but
the point i want to make though is that
look like some really great kinds of
generality the stepping stones are
through specialists what are we gonna do
about that like especially like us like
you could claim that like we're just
gonna go straight to super hyper
generalization like that's where we're
trying to get our super journalists or
something like that by getting more and
more and more general maybe you're right
like deep learning is magic like we just
add more data it's not that simple
though because the fact that we're
admitting we need a curriculum means we
don't have the data so we have to get it
somehow
um but but you also have to just there's
something interesting you have to admit
there's something interesting about when
hyperspecialization actually leads to
generalization and this kind of
paradoxical stepping stone principle
that the things that don't resemble what
you want ultimately are the stepping
stones that get you to it um and hyper
specialization is like a really powerful
thing because it allows you to drop it
allows you to make assumptions like you
can assume something about the
environment you're entering before you
enter because you're a specialist in
that environment and i think that it can
be a disability or a liability like if
you actually go into environments having
no assumptions whatsoever so you have to
be ready for all possible contingencies
under the sun that's what generalization
means in a super general sense like
would you want you know airline pilots
to like not be sure whether they're
flying a stunt jet or a passenger jet
like they've got to do some checks up
front to see which scenario they're in
like if you're just a passenger pilot
you don't do those checks
like you know what you're doing
um and so i think there's there's
there's reason to talk more about this
issue of like the specialization of poet
is actually an interesting facet of it
um and not necessarily just like a
liability that we have to get around
i've just um thought of an interesting
connection that i had hadn't occurred to
me before but there is um a link between
specialization and divergence because if
you think about it a general agent
that's the equivalent of the committee
that you hate so much and the the what
you were just saying with evolution
starting with specialization actually
allows you to explore many many more
interesting stepping stones but um the
thing i want to get to though is
intelligence must be specialized uh i
mean certainly even in conceptions like
aix
aixi
it's framed in terms of being able to
perform tasks in certain environments
there's no such thing as general
intelligence so if you were an alien
being and you came down to planet earth
would you really see that much of a
difference between our kind of
intelligence and photosynthesis
so um that is really interesting um
it it clearly originates from
specialization like i don't think you
can deny that like the explanatory
apparatus or through specialization why
is it what it is
like you're it's related to the
environment we're in i mean that that
must be true obviously so it has to do
with with optimizing within that
environment
but i feel like what's going on is it's
like something to do with like from that
specialization has emerged real general
generality like i feel like we our
intelligence is sufficiently general
to move outside of um
anything in our environment at all like
it gets to this question like where if
people sometimes say like there are
certain things we cannot understand like
it's impossible like as human beings
it's usually like why can't we why would
there be things we can't understand well
it's like they're just so far outside of
our environment like they have nothing
to do with anything experience i think i
don't really fall into that cube i think
i think we have the capacity to
understand literally anything well um
given enough information like obviously
we can't know about things that we can't
actually like observe at all
so we don't know those things um but
like if i was given information i
believe i could understand the concept
like i could understand where did the
universe come from if if you told me
what happened like i think there's there
is some it has nothing to do with what
the kind of situation i come from but i
think i have the capacity to generality
so i think it's it's really interesting
that that like somehow a degree of
generality
emerged from this specialization which
goes beyond
just being good in this environment
could i distinguish so though because
jeff hawkins made this point in his book
as well that what's interesting about
humans is for the first time knowledge
and genes have been separated so i
completely appreciate what you're saying
that aren't we we can understand the
universe and everything in it but our
behavioral intelligence is still very
much tied to our environment i don't
know whether you're familiar with james
lovelock and his gaia theory and he he
essentially thinks of all life on on the
planet as being kind of like an
ecosystem or a meta ecosystem
so could you could you think of humans
as just being a product of our
environment in that same way
is our intelligence
limited by the environment we're in
i mean we are um
i do our intelligence is
does it has
like um
some areas where it's more elastic than
others i i guess because of our
environment i think that would be true
like there are some things that are
easier to grok than other things
because the things that used to the croc
are more aligned with where we come from
um and so that's like what conceptually
we're adapted for like things like the
difference between the third dimension
and the fourth dimension like it's easy
to reason in three dimensions it's quite
hard to reason in four dimensions so we
just aren't really adapted to that does
it mean that i can't understand i don't
think it means i can't understand but
it's just not as flexible it's not as
elastic
um and so i guess i'm going somewhere in
the middle maybe this little bit of
keith's going to the middle i don't like
i yeah i don't think either extreme like
we we're completely specialized i don't
think so uh we're like absolutely like
generalist in the most like flexible
sense no
we're somewhere in the middle but i
think that the toolbox we have is
sufficient i do believe to ultimately
capture anything i do think we could do
that
yeah so i i would i would argue it's
probably an open question i think this
may be a case where um maybe you're
being too certain because
when you talk about like these
dimensionality things you know i know
there are many mathematical structures
that exhibit
very
different you know fundamentally
different behavior and say five
dimensions versus six dimensions versus
eight and i think
sure people have figured that out and we
did that by externalizing that
intelligence writing down symbolics
doing a bunch of equations but i think
it would be fair to say that no human
being has ever claimed that they could
grok that in their mind like they they
can do it by virtue of this externalized
intelligence but to really hold it in
their brain and kind of intuit over it
you know my guess would be there
probably are limitations um to what we
can do and that's one of the things that
excites me about the potential for hei
um i don't know if we're ever gonna get
to it but if we ever do get to it it
would be really interesting to see what
it's capable of
um unshackled by the fact that it you
know that we evolved in a three plus one
dimensional um environment you know to
survive
yeah yeah good points those are really
good points and it's that's interesting
to think about yeah you're right i
hadn't thought of that angle about um
that ai has this potential to break out
of that box and
that is that is an interesting thing
about agi
um so yeah okay point taken um there may
be
yeah so i i am saying something extreme
if i claim that we can understand
everything that is extreme um right i
guess i'll still stick with my claim but
um
but it might take a lot of effort i
guess well the way i see it the way i
see it and and i and i think you may be
right about this at least from this
perspective is that
it may be it may well be the case that
something like uh you know
second order logic or or category theory
or these sorts of logics that we've
already discovered it may turn out to be
the case that they're mathematically
sufficient
to describe any conceivable phenomenon
that we'll
observe in this universe and so i guess
i would say you could be right that our
our languages and our methods that we
developed uh kind of externalized from
us and something that we participate in
have reached this kind of ultimate level
of generality i just think it's a little
bit beyond what a single human mind at
least at this phase of our evolution can
comprehend i'm pretty that's that's
interesting because that actually starts
to go into this issue of what it means
to understand and like this this debate
about like do you do these ais really
understand and
um yeah there's like different kind of
levels of that so it's true that
when i say like we can understand
everything it's a little unclear what i
mean by understand like does it mean
just just apply the right logical
language to describe the phenomenon even
though we don't really get that like
flash feeling of like wow i really get
it
maybe that maybe they're right maybe
that is out of reach
keith why don't you just go and look up
our definition of understanding i i can
give you the definition of reasoning
that we came up with which is the
ability to derive new knowledge from
existing knowledge and experience
right but this reasoning thing is a big
thing you know when we say neural
networks don't reason a lot of it has to
do with this notion of extrapolation and
people talk about the very geometric
notion of extrapolation but we're
talking about being able to
execute a function in some
you know logical discrete space
so to be able to take something we know
and extrapolate it into a new situation
spoken like gary marcus and i'm sure
you've had this conversation with gary
many times
um yeah gary has very strong feelings
about understanding that's true
um yeah
very interesting feelings about that so
it just took me a bit to go look up
because we we did have some some episode
where we were really getting into
defining some of these these concepts
with gary right and at least here's how
i define these so maybe we get your take
on it could be fun so
it's that
reasoning is the act of deriving new
knowledge from prior knowledge plus new
information
uh semantics a mapping from structures
whether mathematical logical symbolic or
other structures to
physical reality
and understanding we had as the act of
deriving new semantic mappings from
prior semantics plus new knowledge
bit esoteric but that's how we defined
it
so understanding is you know is really
was the ability to like okay if i have a
world model that understands something
about physics
you know that like gravity exists and
and balls roll and whatever and somebody
gives me a new some new knowledge which
says
you know hey um this ball is actually
hollow
you know from kind of my understanding
of physics i can now
and i just use the word because i
understand the semantic model
and you give me this new knowledge i can
now derive new
semantics i can say well the ball is
going to behave now in this way in other
words i have a new mapping to the this
physical world because i've gained new
knowledge
um that's kind of the way in which we
perceived understanding so would like
that this is in the context of natural
language
um
you know processing let's say or systems
that do that gpt3 or whatever
because it doesn't have the semantic
model of the world if you say something
like the beer fell off the table
it may not be able to derive that now
the floor is wet and and somebody might
slip if they fall um that that requires
this kind of extra level of
understanding
yeah and and
that that's um filling in the the gaps
as well so a lot of
nlu people say that the one thing neural
networks can't do is extrapolate over
the missing information and that's a
great example so you could reason that
we've just knocked the beer off the
table now the floor's wet
so there's a there's a kind of
exponential space of missing information
that we need reasoning to fill in
okay
i
i have to admit that i um
to probably disappoint you because i'm
not i'm not i'm not i don't really like
definitions
i just never find
definition discussions engaging or
really helpful to me i really some
people i i again i often find that that
appeal to definition is often just a way
of escaping an uncomfortable situation i
want to go towards the uncomfortable
situation so it's like we often will say
well no one's really clearly defined
consciousness like first before i'm
going to discuss it you need to define
it to my satisfaction
well okay we're obviously not going to
discuss it then like i'll never satisfy
you right
and so
it's often in you know ai or decades of
discussion what is intelligence
um and we we see it in even
open-endedness we start having a problem
like in this small field like there's
their open-endedness workshops that come
it's like half the papers were just like
what dubbing is like long pages and
pages of definition and terms it's like
well are we going to ever do anything or
just we're going to argue about this for
the next decade like what is what are we
even talking about is what we're going
to talk about
um and i feel like a lot of this is not
uh not necessary i feel like i can i can
talk about consciousness i can't define
it for you to your satisfaction i can
talk about intelligence i can make
progress on intelligence i can talk
about open-endedness i don't care really
what the definition is it's just you're
going to use it to stop me from talking
so the the only thing i'll defend there
is that uh i mean
i i'm again i'm a pragmatist i believe
in defining things to the extent
necessary to communicate and so we have
to have you know it's kind of like going
back to the whole um you know hyper
specialization leading to innovation you
know if you just have a divergent
divergent thing i think i made this
point in our in our first video you're
just gonna end up with a universe of
gray goo
like the really fascinating thing is
that because there are these constraints
of you need to survive in order to pass
on your information you wind up with
this kind of beautiful tapestry of
hyper-specialized things that recombine
to become
more general and you know it's far more
interesting than either extreme like
either the gray goo
or like the you know the nothing you
know and and so as far as definitions go
i think that um
i i don't like to sit there and and
pedantically argue forever about what
the definition of intelligence is but we
need to have
enough of a definition that we can make
progress in learning and kind of doing
scientific discoveries so things like
the the beer falls off the table and
it's wet well if
a if a system
can't figure that out
we notice that it can't figure out kind
of a class of things and that class of
things has something in common and we
give it a name and maybe it's
understanding or whatever i don't care
but it's just a way of talking about
that class of
of problems with things that's not able
to achieve because then we can try and
figure out how to do that
yeah yeah
yeah i think that the symbolists though
that when they
when they um come up with formal
arguments
it's not that doesn't come first they
notice that neural networks can't do
something which is to say they they
can't fill in the the missing gaps and
then they come up with a formalism to
express why that is and also many of
these symbolists believe that there are
kind of platonic um abstractions that
exist in the universe they think that
mathematics is discovered not invented
so so that so that kind of formal um
apparatus is how they understand the
world
well i i feel like i should try to
solidify my attack on definition since
it's obviously a fairly again radical
thing to say
um i
i i would acknowledge look in the sense
that keith is saying that
again like i don't want to be a prank
like obviously you need to define some
terms sometimes like that's obviously
clear that should be completely clear
i'm not against that like you know
especially like you're you're gonna
derive something and you're writing a
paper or you have a certain set of
assumptions you need to know what they
are like in order to prove that it
actually is true or not true if that's
what you're trying to do like that makes
total sense to me
um so not i'm not a blanket saying we
shouldn't have definitions but i think
the thing about definitions that's
interesting like a lot of things is that
there just isn't solid ground like in
terms of like they're just generally
good for you like they can be good for
you or they can be bad for you they can
be a tool of clarification or they can
be a tool of obfuscation and it depends
how you use them and i often find them
to be tools of obfuscation like
especially when we're talking about
things we don't know which is once again
the problem which is what i'm interested
in i want to talk about things that we
don't know and that seems where people
get really passionate about definitions
so it's like what does it mean to
understand we don't know i don't know
what i do know though i'm confident
there's such a thing there is
understanding it might be a continuum
maybe it's not just a binary concept
beyond that i don't really know what it
means
um and so i would be interested to talk
in depth like what does this really mean
like let's look at this um
but no we have to like we just end up in
this like a big argument about the
definition
um and i find that in that case it's
obfuscation because it's fear because
really like if your whole pitch is like
your thing that you get a lot of
traction on is basically attacking the
fact that things don't understand um
then you might be a little uncomfortable
if we really start dissecting what you
mean and so you should just comment us
and just tell us like hey you're not
even being clear in your terms here and
just stop the argument in his tracks
and that's the kind of definition i
don't like i mean i'd rather just like
look we agree there's i don't know
exactly what it is you don't know
exactly what it is let's talk about it
anyway it's uncomfortable um but there
is such a thing that's what we should
agree do we agree there's understanding
like do is understand me exist
well see that's the problem is
right but that's the problem is you can
run into fun some folks that will go
that extreme and say there's no such
thing as intelligence it's it's all just
yeah so but look i agree with you in
principle which is again
i like definitions insofar as they're
necessary to enable communication so i'm
totally on board with the idea that we
need to be talking about things and
that's why i kind of like say the
coherence theory of knowledge because it
acknowledges look we're never going to
get to the
the foundation beyond which there's no
other foundation that we can imagine we
just need to
understand far enough and define things
far enough that we can make progress
so um i'm a little bit i can completely
understand where you're coming from
kenneth it
you think that we have a fundamental
fear of the unknown and we're hiding
behind our formalisms
and
my only worry is that it's it seems a
little bit anti-intellectual
because you could you can make an
observation that an ai model is not
behaving the way we are there's loads of
assumptions there we assume that we are
behaving intelligently and we are doing
things the right way but but then you
can say oh um let's resist any formalism
to try and break this down analytically
did you see do you see the conflict
there
yeah absolutely i i mean um
it's a dangerous position because it's
clear that some formalism is necessary
like i tried to concede i mean
i'm walking a tightrope so
it's um it's not yeah it can't be i
can't make i can't make this blanket
claim that like formalism needs to be
completely thrown out the window the w
that was d
that would just destroy my credibility
um
but like the point is these are just
pendulum these are pendulum what is the
plural pendulums
these are pendulums like they swing in
different directions so like like we
become
so enamored with this which is a useful
tool but to the point where it actually
becomes like a form of obfuscation and i
do believe definition is like that like
definition it's not always um and it's
not everybody but like a lot of the time
when like there's an uncomfortable issue
like we immediately jump to definition
to obfuscate i think conscious is one of
the greatest examples of that it's like
there's clearly a mystery here um and i
agree there are a few people who would
disagree there's any mystery at all um
but to me it's clear there's a mystery
don't need to have a definition to know
there's a mystery we could get into why
it's mysterious that's more dis
interesting to me than what the
definition is but if you jump at me with
this definition stuff like you're gonna
stop me from getting into that
i feel like that's pure obfuscation this
is one of the greatest unknown things in
the entire scientific world like
consciousness it's one of the greatest
mysteries of all time
um and like so arguing about definitions
is that really where we're gonna go with
this like we don't need maybe we don't
have a good definition yet because we
don't even know what we're talking about
that's part of why it's so mysterious
i think this is quite interesting though
because with consciousness we clearly
don't have a mental apparatus
um
you know like for example if someone
just took some hallucinogenics and they
just had a completely
crazy visual experience they wouldn't
have any words or any mental framework
to hang this off whereas when we're
talking about an apparatus to describe
intelligent behavior we absolutely do
have an apparatus to hang things off so
i guess
where is it is that a spectrum in your
mind
um
yeah there is a spectrum i i would also
concede that um
and
the
um with with consciousness
yeah it's true that we we lack it it's
much worse for us it's true because it's
ineffable which is another way so you
can't put it into words like all the
things we're discussing have no words um
like the blueness of blue like i can't
actually describe it you can't break it
down into parts or say what it is
um and so that makes it extremely
difficult like to actually get into
anything formal about it
um where's intelligence i would grant
that you can
to some extent like you can actually
point to things that can be reduced to
words um or symbols um or formalism
um and so it's it's a little bit better
on that slippery slope it's higher up
and like less less dangerous
um but still uh i think it's still on a
slippery slope like there's i don't
think we although we can talk about
intelligence more easily than
consciousness i still don't think we
really fully uh grasp this either
or really have the words to really get
at what we're talking about we don't
understand ourselves well enough to
understand what we're talking about
um and so it's there's still a little
bit of this room for obfuscation
where we fail to address the mystery
itself by just deciding to focus on the
definition
yeah i mean i
i think if we did understand it or had a
clear definition you know we wouldn't be
having so many interesting papers coming
out like
on the measure of intelligence and that
was the thing that i liked about
chile's paper is
hey as long as it's an operationally
useful
measure um then then that helps us
it turns out
while it's kind of a nice framework to
think about things there isn't yet a
measure of it um you know kind of
working on that he's working on that but
again i i love the idea that we just
um you know the goal here like you said
earlier is really to talk about things
you know it's to communicate it's to
learn it's to make progress it's to
explore and to some degree to make life
better to exploit but it's all about
just doing almost the minimal necessary
to enable
communication and and exploration i
think
yeah um yeah yeah so i i totally agree
um like the ultimate point is to explore
and um
yeah i just like to go to places that um
are ambiguous like on purpose for some i
feel like that's what we're supposed to
do like if we're talking about science
or art
um those are like the really interesting
uncomfortable places where you're gonna
learn something it's almost like how in
physics physicists always want to go to
where
two two great theories collide and
nobody knows what happens like what
happens at the surface of a black hole
where quantum mechanics and general
relativity collide there's a lot of
unknown and ambiguity there that's where
the real progress is going to come from
you're sitting you're sitting right on
the boundary of chaos and order you're
trying to straddle that that straddle
line exactly exactly
well um professor kenneth stanley it's
it's always an honor thank you so much
for joining us
thank you that was super fun thank you
thank you so much thank you amazing